at this moment we have eight laboratory
confirmed cases in Europe four in France
and four in Germany I am in continuous
contact with the ministers of health of
both France and Germany and I'm assured
that necessary steps to contain the raw
virus have been taken by both countries
all eight persons that I have mentioned
before are under treatment in
specialized infectious disease
departments in France and Germany
extensive contact tracing is underway
and the measures are being taken for the
persons that they have been in contact
with the situation I know that you are
all aware of is both constant complex
and constantly evolving they are still
significant uncertainties about the
source of the infection how virulent and
how pathogenic it is on the science
front you probably know there is
currently no specific treatment no
vaccine for this disease the Member
States reported to us a strong level of
preparedness member states reported
their access to laboratory diagnosis
networks guidance documents that have
been already been prepared for
travellers health care professionals as
well as the general public we have been
working across the general spectrum of
commissioned services and agencies as
well as the council and the European
external Action Service this is to
ensure that the Atmos that we have the
upmost coordinated response and full
activation of all support services in
order to be prepared to mitigate the
consequences of a larger spread of the
virus in the EU
should the situation deteriorate we have
additional measures which could be taken
in addition to those already ongoing
including mobilizing emergency funding
to south support outbreak response as
the outbreak of this virus has
intensified the Commission decided
yesterday to step up our preparedness
and response activities upon the
decision of President Thunder line and
my end in my capacity as the European
emergency response coordinator we have
initiated a strengthened coordination
between our relevant services currently
we are actively coordinating and
accompanying Member States intention to
repatriate EU citizens from China there
are a number of you citizen citizens in
China who would like to leave the
country the current number is about 600
and that they cannot do so at the moment
and as announced yesterday France has
activated the Union Civic protection
mechanism via our Emergency Response
Coordination Center in order to
coordinate the repatriation of EU
citizen citizens from Wuhan with
airplanes
also at this time the French authorities
are in close contact with the Chinese
authorities to work out the operational
details in order to perform the
announced flights it is important to
understand in this context that
regarding the circumstances this is a
very complex operation that requires
time and patience in addition it is also
important to know that the Union Civil
Protection mechanism can also be
deployed outside Europe we are also
following Member States efforts to
control incoming passengers from China
at European airports to sum up the
Commission services have fully engaged
in monitoring and responding to all
possible facets of this outbreak as of
yesterday our management structures have
all been mobilized based on our
knowledge today we expect this
coordinated effort will need to be
pursued in the forthcoming weeks and
probably months